for these young asylum seekers rap music
is an escape from the daily grind we go
on tour with a band that's tired of
waiting for things to change most asylum
seekers go unheard but nori and Hasan
are not like the 130,000 or so other
asylum seekers in Germany they're free
to travel around the country performing
with their band the refugees on stage
they rap about their difficult daily
lives nori in his early 20s is from
Dagestan he spent about half his life in
a refugee center in northern Germany
living in a single room with his parents
and sister
these men are tvs once you shoot their
people tried
Nori's family no longer felt safe in
Dagestan one of the most troubled
provinces in Russia's North Caucasus
region but in Germany they live in
constant fear of deportation
unimaginable for most Germans Scott
ovations I've got some people come to
our concerts and say that they didn't
know anything about the problem finish
cut open his girl top but they say that
what we sing about in our songs and our
message is really shocking these people
never realize this problem existed in
Germany lets us be I'm Kobe misalucha
german singer songwriter heinz rats came
up with the idea of setting up a band
with asylum seekers their songs deal
with topics that include german
politicians attitudes toward refugees
life for asylum seekers is talk in
Germany rots saw that for himself on a
charity concert tour of asylum seekers
hostels I have 5000 ever visited about
80 hostels in 2011 I was totally
horrified you really upset I couldn't
get it out of my mind suneel said
tallest muster and I wonder how I could
create something beautiful out of all
this misery then I realized how many
musicians there were there stewing in
their own juices about any opportunity
to play their own songs that's why I
invited them to Hamburg where we
recorded a CD no we're on tour
that's how he met nori and hossain for
them the refugees project is a dream
come true for the first time someone is
interested in their story
eighteen-year-old hossain fled Iran
because he couldn't be a rapper their
shop sofa the stuff but I had so many
arguments with my father he told me we
were living in a Muslim country and I
was making the music of infidels on
demoth music fun woof ha saenz parents
had themselves fled their homeland of
Afghanistan for Iran but in Iran being a
hip-hopper is fraught with danger when
Hussein was 15 he wrote a song that was
critical of Islam vishva Fulton is when
I was 15 years old i ended up behind
bars for six months in a children's
prison the key thing is not bunking and
they beat me every day and then I didn't
think of it it's up just luck with home
hossein decided to flee the country it
took him two years to get to Germany
Europe is tough and dangerous journey he
never gave up the hope of a better
future the two musicians have gotten to
know Germany well thanks to the project
normally asylum seekers are not allowed
to travel around freely hossein and nori
have special permits allowing them to
leave the region where they live
Karen rostock they have as usual invited
asylum seekers to attend their concert
for free of course it's a welcome change
in there otherwise monotonous everyday
lives the concerts of straw man Vasa
featuring the refugees are among the few
opportunities that asylum seekers have
to actually meet Germans the project is
one recognition band leader hines Watts
has been awarded germany's integration
metal give is ash what's this value
autism is medal offers a certain degree
of protection the german government has
made the project official i mean they
can hardly give me this award and then
deport the refugees involved i think the
authorities also realize this but it's
no guarantee the refugees can stay and
as much as they enjoy performing their
music they still have some unfulfilled
wishes so that's my first of all my
family I really miss him I haven't seen
them for more than three years on a
fight about the second thing I don't
think it's possible but we're trying to
achieve it anyway in a world without
borders and racism on another
here this world is already a reality
asylum seekers and Germans mixing freely
in the audience and on the stage thanks
to this project Narayan Hussein's lives
in Germany have gained some meaning
you
you